is this even real
sponsored by Ipana toothpaste
I pan a toothpaste yep now they put the
best sponsors for Gutfeld
and tonight is this even real a grocery
store in Austria I didn't even know that
Austria was real anymore right didn't
they change their name no anyway stop it
Martha don't fact check me
apparently Austria has reportedly been
shut down because there's a dangerous
spider hiding in a bunch of bananas and
the spider if it bites you could give
men permanent
erections
we go live to a local bar for reaction
[Applause]
cat I go to you first is this story real
I think it's made up really yeah I think
that's some guy at some point had an
erection when he wasn't supposed to and
he was like babe it must have been the
banana spider
a spider and the banana I ate earlier
and all of his boys are backing them up
like yeah that totally happened to me
too
and now here we are now and all these
men going there because claiming to have
low potassium
listen nobody wants that power nobody
will yeah what are you gonna do with it
no because right yeah most of the week
you'll just other than hang in a hat or
a coat really it's not going to change
her attitude
well it's like that all the time so we
can just I'll just get back to you on
Monday yeah exactly it's not going
anywhere it's not going anywhere but
yeah no actually this is true
it does but it's not as it's not as fun
as you think fellas yeah it's you
shouldn't you're an expert in this sort
of yeah well if I get bit by a spider I
don't know what time it is but yeah they
do live in and they bite you yeah oh
yeah rock hard you can cut diamonds the
cold part is eventually it will explode
no one's wanting to go near that yeah so
for all you guys running to bananas to
get bit
[Music]
you know it's funny
I'm still like you know Martha I'm still
hung up on the Austria part did you know
anybody who's gone to Austria like it's
not Australia no it's not Germany it's
this weird mix of Australia and Germany
Austria no not really it's actually
Austria no I went twice last year it's
its own country it's been its own
country since the austro-hungarian
Empire
it's not Australia it's Sound of Music
it's not like Czechoslovakia which is
Czech Republic and Slovakia now maybe
you were thinking about that is it but I
just am so happy that I don't have to
talk about the spider and like the
impact I think I covered
um yes they should call it the wandering
eye spider because uh and I think it's
probably scarier to most men than a
Barbie movie lately yes that's true
although but Austria is definitely a
country put it on your country list
I've been there it's a nice place what's
the capital of Austria Germany Germany
um
all right Jamie
um close out this show with uh a
sparkling example of your wit with jokes
that require long setups well first of
all I hope this is true or I wasted a
lot of money this weekend
on a tattoo that says here spider spider
[Laughter]
um
I look deeper into this it's a four you
get a four hour erection oh man I
haven't had one of those since women's
volleyball was in the Olympics
[Laughter]
that's good keep going we have some time
I'm not letting you off the hook yeah
use some of the material you think it's
too edgy
isn't this though I thought side effects
yeah permanent erection seems like it
seems long right yeah yes he was too
long like I thought side effects had to
be negative well you know
this is you do bring up an interesting
point like you know what's weird is
those weren't very good jokes but like
whenever there's a subject about
literally any other story you have like
10 boner jokes yeah right but but then
it's about a boner I got nothing yeah
you just crack under the pressure
it's the fear of the unknown you want
the spider to bite you and you don't
want the spider to bite you but there's
a chance the spider can bite you and
somehow you can walk around the rest of
your life 10 hunting everybody maybe
it's just crazy enough to work no you
have you have a kickstand no
yes when it comes to boner jokes he has
performance anxiety yeah oh yeah boner
jokes and in bed it's okay
we've all been there
it's all right Jamie just say Austria
the street isn't it Schwarzenegger from
Austria yeah of course exactly it's not
real we'll be right back hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else